on est dans le sud-ouest dans le
périgord noir dans l'un des plus beaux
coins de france entre sarlat et
rocamadour
il se décide dans cette forêt je me suis
cachée pour pour quelques mois c'est
assez haut pour pour m'éloigner un petit
peu du monde et fait une vraie coupure
ici à mon bureau je me suis assis pour
écrire mon journal de cabanes pour
bouquiner ici des bocaux avec des
réserves
gimont harmonica des appeaux pour
appeler les oiseaux mes jumelles ma
loupe de botanistes un bois de cerf
indique corps retrouvé à 30 mètres de la
cabane le coin cuisine de ce côté là
n'avaient sel on lit sur le haut un lit
en mezzanine ici toujours le coin
cuisine
voilà je vais ranger les torchons avec
les réserves de nourriture de ce côté
quelques outils le coin vaisselle et
toilettes et la terrasse mon balcon sur
la forêt
j'étais dans une sorte de mélancolie
intérieur on dire aujourd'hui un burn
out parce que j'ai été éleveur de brebis
pendant sept ans que c'est un métier
difficile et que j'allais petit à petit
j'allais d'échec en échec dans mon
métier d'éleveur et puis est venue un
jour où j'ai vendu mon troupeau et une
grande douleur est venue celle de
l'échec professionnel l'échec agricole
peut être aussi l'échec d'un rêve ou
d'un idéal et pour conjurer le sort je
me suis dit que faut-il faire
et c'est là où cyrano m'a soufflé l'idée
à la fin de son livre
elles m'ont rostand prête à cyrano
inverse magnifique cyrano est agonisant
après avoir reçu à voir a été attaqué et
on veut le soutenir on veut placer un
fauteuil et cyrano s'appuie un arbre et
il dit non non ne me soutenaient pas
rien que l'arbre j'avais négligé j'avais
jamais lu c'est vers là et en relisant
sciemment je me dis c'est incroyable que
rostand donne à cyrano cette idée que
l'on peut avoir recours à l'arbre rien
que l'arbre j'ai vécu ici pendant trois
mois une véritable sobriété heureuse
dirait pierre rabhi par exemple j'ai
passé des journées à tailler des
cuillères com
celle là qui est une ébauche avec un
couteau croche alors je passais comme ça
là à creuser et ça j'avais l'impression
de reprendre un peu de pouvoir sur la
vie en faisant des gestes tout simples
par la main mon activité était très très
hermétique le matin lever au lever du
soleil couché au couchant un peu de
sport un peu de lecture de l'écriture de
mon journal de cabanes et puis
l'observation
j'ai été émerveillé par un papillon
qu'on appelle les papillons citron qui
sont des papillons jaune avec parfois
quelques détails noirs sur les ailes
j'étais aussi très chanceux dans cette
forêt parce que au piémont chaînes ont
éclos 3 lys martagon qui sont des lices
assez rare délices des forêts magnifique
j'avais envie de danser avec eux quand
ils ont fleuri comme ça incroyable et
puis est venue une surprise au delà des
oiseaux des sittelles des grains pro des
mésanges dérives et des rapaces est
venue à los rios qui est un oiseau
migrateur un oiseau tout jaune avec des
grandes ailes noires il est venue un
matin me faire courir comme ça dans les
feuilles du chêne jeu dans mon lit c'est
lui qui m'a réveillé et je vois depuis
mon lit par l'oculus je vois cet oiseau
qui descend comme ça dans les branches
avec un pas un peu pesant je me suis
jamais ennuyé en forêt jamais tout est
là l'inattendu est là
les enfants et la famille sont venus une
fois à peu près une fois par semaine le
dimanche
il venait on a passé des très belles
heures ici ou faisait du feu à côté de
l'arbre pour pique [ __ ] et puis la fin
de mon séjour au printemps les enfants
sont venus au mois de juin
un parent je les ai invités dans la
cabane et on a passé des très beaux
moments à tailler des cuillères là par
exemple j'ai l'exemple de l'écuyère que
j'ai fait pour les enfants une cuillère
en bouillie une cuillère en merisier une
cuillère en bois de cèdre tout ça c'est
des petits objets de cabanes qui ont
fait partie de ce que j'aime à
transmettre avec mes enfants vers
l'école buissonnière depuis l'âge de 19
ans je n'ai pas arrêté d'être dans le
mouvement s'était paris saigon de
chevaux c'était encore une exploration
avec sylvain tesson et thomas goisque en
haut du mont ararat tu pendant 20 ans je
n'ai fait que chercher autour du monde
parle ailleurs par le voyage un
dépaysement peut-être une fuite
je crois que c'est auprès de mon chêne
comme le chantait brassens que j'ai
trouvé le plus de quiétude le plus de 2
de calme subi de tranquillité c'est dans
l'immobilité
j'ai trouvé le plus de tranquillité
je me suis profondément senti exister
j'ai vécu parmi les heures les plus
belles de ma vie parce que j'ai senti le
temps s'écoule et loin des injonctions
de du mail auquel il faut répondre c'est
le très joli mot qu'on connaît de
bernanos c'est à dire que on a rien
compris à la modernité si on n'a pas
compris qu'elle était un complot contre
la vie intérieure est en fait ce que je
suis venu chercher ici c'est à sortir de
peut-être de ce complot contre la vie
intérieure et à retrouver une forme
d'attention
or cette attention je les trouvais par
le minuscule je les trouvais en
observant le fait d'avoir retrouvé ces
petites choses très simples je dirais la
nature du silence et du temps voilà
comment je me suis retrouvé la solitude
dont parle victor hugo quand je suis
parmi vous arbre de ces grands bois dans
tout ce qui m'entoure et me cache à la
fois dans votre solitude où je rentre en
moi même je sens quelqu'un de grand qui
m'écoutent et qui m'aiment et bien comme
je suis avec victor hugo dans cette
cabane jeu sans quelqu'un de grand qui
m'écoutait qui m'aiment et la solitude
jamais ne me pèse et c'est pour ça que
j'ai maman faut rester parce que
peut-être que parlant forrest mans je me
retrouve un peu et je retrouve les amis